Al Michaels joining us now did you have
the under or over for us with this show
let me start with this I woke up this
morning you were on my mind
remember the we5 had that song the boys
you know you're much too young and I'm
so I wake up I'm gonna shave and wash my
face turn on NBCSN and there you are
with my man Johnny Bench yes since I did
the Reds in seventy one two and three
talking about his protective gear yes
right
so what a way to what a way to open up
open up the show by the way
congratulations on anniversary number
ten I'm listening to you guys talk about
what it was like you know in your house
on the third floor it's like what the
oranges can in a string clothes I mean
it really was that these guys their
dedication to making just get on the air
was incredible it wasn't we didn't worry
about what we did when we got on the air
we just wanted to make sure we were
actually making contact with radio
stations around the country and look at
you now I know right man caves all over
the United States I see you know Dan's
getting off private planes you guys
getting off the Greyhound these guys off
the bus there but thank you though
thank you for your contributions here
and we appreciate that not lost on us
that you've makin you've made the time
to to be available well I could make the
time because I have to get up for the
opening bell oh that's that's why you
gotta it's the great thing about living
on the west coast and that's I brought
up that I grew up a Reds fan I was very
fortunate that I had that team I think
it's still the best national league team
that's ever been put on the field but I
also had Alduin play-by-play I didn't I
just knew I was very good and you're
probably 27 and at the time right and
I'm listening to the Reds on radio and
I'm listening to Al do the Reds games in
the early 70s so I had the Big Red
Machine and I had one of the great
broadcasters of all time I was pretty
lucky you know it was so hard for me is
I mean I got a tremendous break and I
was hired by Bob Howsam and Dick Wagner
and it was 26 when they got the job and
I'm coming in from Hawaii and the town
is going well you know what is this we
got a Hawaiian guy 26 years old he's
gonna do our Cincinnati Reds so Joe
Nuxhall embraced me and
and the town we'd worked out extremely
well but it was funny because I could
see by my third year this is one of the
great baseball teams of all time rose in
his prime bench approaching his prime
trade from Joe Morgan concepción who you
talked about before Geronimo we bring up
Ken Griffey senior spark he's the
manager the pitching staffs pretty good
going of the World Series and I know the
Giants San Francisco they're gonna come
after me and they tripled my salary but
I'm sitting there that third year going
man alive I am leaving one of the great
teams in the history of baseball and so
I had to I left because you triple your
salary what I'm gonna do is I go to the
Giants who are more abundant they were
terrible but you know it was a good gig
for me and the morning Brennaman took
over for me and Marty is still there how
cool was that and a Hall of Famer and a
Hall of Fame himself yeah yeah but did
you get Willie Mays Willie Mays had gone
he'd left no Willie Mays the last game I
do for the Reds is when we the Reds lose
in the playoffs to the Mets in 73
that's the rose Harrelson here right you
know in Game three but Willie Mays was
playing for the Mets okay at that time
so I wanted the last game I do for the
Reds well the Mays is playing for for
the Mets it I don't know if it affects
how you call the game but when you're
watching somebody that you think might
be their last game or in the Twilight
you know how do you add perspective or
is it your position to add that
perspective of Willie Mays you could
make the case is one of the top five
players of all time but we saw him at
the end with the Mets and everybody
talks about how he kind of went out not
looking anything like he once was you
know it's funny you mentioned this
because I did Reggie Miller's last game
I did when I did the NBA for two years
in the early 2000s we went into
Indianapolis and we did a piston pacer
game and the Pistons were going to
clinch that series and advance to the
finals and we knew it was Reggie's last
game so I it's it's funny you trust to
put things in perspective you don't know
for a fact that it's gonna be his last
game but I remember one of the great
things that happened in that game is
Detroit's gonna win Larry Brown is
coaching the Pistons and Larry called
the timeout in the last like 45 seconds
to enable I think was Rick Carlisle I
was coaching the Pacers that at that
time to get Reggie out of the game so he
to get that tremendous ovation otherwise
the game ends and you know Reggie's
career ends and and that's that so that
was fun to do I wound up doing crazily
enough and you don't know it at the time
but when I did the Reds against the
Pirates in the championship series in
1972 they turned out to be Roberto
Clemente's last game because he would
die in a plane crash the following New
Year's Eve so that turned out to be his
last game you know so that you don't
know Reggie you knew and you do try to
put things in perspective if you can you
know as best you can but without
overdoing it I'm curious your take on
what Tony Romo his style as a
play-by-play guy and because I think Jim
Nantz is doing an incredible job it's
sort of filling in what Tony because
Tony feels like he's leading the
broadcast Jim sort of just grabbing it
and then steering it in the right
direction but how how difficult is that
with what is going on at CBS with Tony
Romo it's no surprise to me that they
are a great pairing and Jim and I talked
the three or four years ago when we
talked about who would the players who
were playing at that particular time who
would make the best broadcasters and
Peyton Manning was still playing so you
know Peyton would be great if he decides
to get into the business we both agreed
though that Tony Romo would have a
tremendous career and then as it turns
out of course the opportunity was
presented to Tony he takes it I think
he'll be there for 20 years you know
they worked very hard in the off season
just putting things together and I spent
some time with Tony when he was out here
in July and he's totally immersed in it
he wanted to know everything about
everything about the production how
things work what are people doing in the
truck and that's what makes to me the
really great analysts are the guys who
don't come off the field and go in
effect hey you know I played the game
and I know and blah blah blah blah blah
anybody can do that anybody the guys who
are really terrific and I go back to
like the Tim McCarver ease of the world
Hawaii I worked with and Dan Dierdorf
and of course I've got you know the best
of all time and Chris Collins were there
John Madden they new television
production they understood what
communication was about they understood
not on
did they know the game but how do relate
to the fans how to make an interesting
how to make it exciting how to make it
humorous Tony's got it I mean he's off
to the best start imaginable and they
make a great pairing but what do you
think when he's calling out the plays I
think that's good for it has a little
bit of a shelf life you could do that
once in a while and I know that you know
the New York Times did a big piece
lording him for predicting click well
that's that's that's all well and good
but in the ultimate you want to be just
you want to be the whole body of work
and it's you know Hank Stram did that a
lot they're gonna run left they're gonna
run right nobody said wow that's great
well I think most people could do that I
mean if the tight end lines up on the
right side there's a pretty good chance
they're gonna run right if they're gonna
run it so it's fun and and and Tony's
done a great job in terms of you know
predicting plays but I think in the in
the in the long run you do that once in
a while but there were other factors
that make you a really great broadcaster
but like I say I mean he's a can't-miss
and he'll be there for 20 years you know
I think Collinsworth does it in a subtle
way just to say keep an eye on and and I
think that's what Tony will probably
settle into where it's just more of a
quick little burst you know like hey
keep an eye bottom of the screen you
know that matchup sure and you know that
way then it allows Nance to take it and
actually do the play-by-play well I mean
what makes Chris so great is that when
he does it it's unbelievably relevant
what we did we did a San Diego a New
Orleans game at five or six years ago
and they put so much pressure on rivers
from the New Orleans defensive line and
Chris said if they can't block I can't
remember who the guy was this game was
gonna be over and that's how the game
ended so he could see it he saw where
the vulnerability was he understood it
he didn't overwhelm you with it but once
in a while you know and Chris sees
something he'll he'll point it out and
then it's fantastic you know you at home
know where to look and what to look for
it's interesting that you you single out
that moment because I remember saying to
my boss Sam flooded NBC I said
Collinsworth just won the Sports Emmy
mm-hmm with that right there yeah and he
ended up winning it it wasn't for just
that right but it was that that was the
you know the microcosm of what makes
Collins we're so grateful
we'll continue with Al Michaels it's a
15 after the hour update the poll
results here I want to ask him his
advice for the LA Chargers and how they
can become relevant you're smiling now I
I'm gonna give you time to come up with
an answer go into the parking 15 after
the hour this is the Dan Patrick show
more important for the Patriots tonight
are the Buccaneers first of all there's
no such thing as a must-win game in Week
five right when is there a must-win
search there's a must-win game when
you're eliminated from either playoff
contention or from the playoffs okay the
Super Bowl is a must-win game right the
AFC or NFC championship game is a
must-win game but apart from that there
are no such things as must-win games in
week five so I would say tonight's key
you know you can look at it two ways
here the Patriots play in a division
where even though Buffalo is three in
one I get it in New England's one the
Jets and one as many games as New
England has you don't discount the
Patriots ever you know they have huge
problems defensively they'll probably
get those fixed I would think but Tampa
it's a big game I mean they play in a
division right now Carolina's off to a
good story you know you've got New
Orleans there as well so and tamp is an
interesting team that one of those teams
at the beginning of the season we all
looked at and we said you know if
there's kind of a sleeper team yeah so
maybe more important for Tampa tonight
the New England all right we took a
break but before taking the break I said
that you're gonna come up with maybe a
way to fix the Chargers here is their
way short-term to fix the Chargers
short-term yeah I think you can do maybe
a little better marketing in a way I
mean it's a small Stadium it's being
filled up by teams by fans from other
teams I heard last week they put up a
let's go Chargers thing on the message
board and they were drowned out by let's
go Eagles to me it will work eventually
it's about the stadium it's always been
about the stadium and that stadium won't
be open until 2020 so in the meantime
they're playing at the you know it
StubHub 20 some odd thousand seats the
rams are there are a lot of empty seats
at the Rams game I mean the Colosseum is
a relic and I know they fill it up for
SC and all of that I get that but it's a
relic and I know a lot of people who
won't go to the Colosseum because it's
just it's too tough to sit in the middle
of a row with you know 20 people and you
try to go to the bathroom and get a
hotdog gonna take forever so eventually
when that new stadium opens up that will
be a big draw the Chargers just and yeah
they have to hang on in the way and plus
you know if you win it's it's big it's
their own for right now and they've what
three home games in a row that they've
lost so I think in the long run
yes and you and I have talked about this
for years 20 million people live in
Southern California 20 million you can
put 60,000 or 70,000 butts in seats you
can do that eventually
you can't stop hobbies everybody was
sitting on top of each other but
eventually when they opened up the new
stadium I think it'll all come around
yes Pauline Dan another surprise caller
he's at Los Angeles sports fan of course
and he also has a show called Curb Your
Enthusiasm Larry David Klein Oh
[Applause]
Larry thank you you're so smart hi Larry
hey Thank You Larry Larry says you're so
smart Oh what what are you doing up
Larry what are you doing over this hour
Larry when am I gonna get invited to
Riviera now that Bel Air's closed for
nine months I'm holding your feet to the
fire Larry we appreciate your calling in
and go ahead and say some nice things
about me in the show then that'd be
great dan you are just so wonderful you
know that everybody knows that ten years
yes here's what I want to do okay
as soon as as soon as curb is over I
want to I want to join the the little
Dennis I want to be a Dennis I think
would be a fantastic job I envy the
Dennis now I can you get by on 30
seven thousand dollars a year you know
what I think I can't okay I appreciate
that
now I full disclosure I did call you out
yesterday because I was told through a
friend of yours that apparently you have
an airplane episode coming out in Curb
Your Enthusiasm a seat situation with
the bathroom issues Fritzi brought that
up on the show on time so just a
coincidence is this inspired by
real-life events from Fritzie that you
putted it have you have you filmed and I
think believe it's the sixth episode
this year where there's a bathroom issue
where somebody wants to change seats
with you I believe and you write you
refuse to have you filmed that okay all
right well that takes you off the hook
for stealing sampling from from and
Larry what was it a g5 or a falcon mm he
had this bathroom a cigar
Larry goes commercial commercial yes I
heard you big cheapskate you went to
Chicago with all those golf guys are you
flew Southwest I heard right Larry but
dense don't you like the common man
who's taken like you have a Doc Rivers
wasn't happy about that he wanted the
charger by the way how good are you at
golf Larry I saw the episode with the
Swan when you kill the Swan and the
swing looks pretty athletic there it's
almost a Bill Murray
hey I'll just say this I'm not good but
I'm better than out you're right that
doesn't make you good that is not fake
news he's right but you belong to
Riviera I do yeah well don't say it that
way I mean you know like you sounded
like you know hey I'm embarrassed to
belong to Riviera not bel-air without I
never do well it by B then that first
tee the whole course
just never do well there now once again
we want to say thank you for calling in
obviously and good luck with this won't
be the final season of curb right I hope
not if I do another season I'm not gonna
wait five years I could tell you that
okay so then you would just bounce right
into the next season
not wait and make everybody kind of hold
their breath okay well thank you for
calling it L is there anything you'd
like to add to the conversation with
Larry before you say goodbye what time
were we team by the way your jets are
doing great
oh god please no you want two games what
if I can give you Josh Rosen at UCLA or
Sam darn 'old which one which
quarterback do you want with the Jets
Thank You Larry Thank You ver that's the
great Larry David I am yeah with Al
Michaels right after this all he says
that he has to step out for a moment
here maybe we we tried to order because
we had only had a slice of apple pie for
our celebration of 10 years no we
ordered a cake from where this cool spot
called Jerry's in torrents the cake shop
that's 24 hours yeah and they're trying
to get it here but you know it's be
tough we asked the owner if he could
come by and bring it but it's gonna be
tough wait I got about 20 more minutes
oh yeah
heavy heavy traffic on the 405 oh it is
always it's amazing how much of the
conversation of locals in Los Angeles
deals with traffic it's horrible can you
do you go like how long do you go before
you something that has to do with Los
Angeles traffic tonight the Kings open
up their season the LA Kings getting on
big Kingston yeah so the game I think is
at 7 o'clock I will leave from here to
get I mean this is crazy
it's it takes me 22 minutes for that
traffic and about an hour and 10 with
traffic it's it's insane in Los Angeles
it's insane almost everywhere [ __ ] you
know we travel around the corner
we're always getting into traffic James
but it's particularly crazy here I
always when I'm driving I'll go oh there
must be an accident and then you realize
no that and then there's no accident it
was just sheer volume sure volume and
then you know two o'clock in the morning
occasionally I'll fly back in after a
game and three lanes are closed
construction for Caltrans work so you
have another traffic jam oh I'm telling
you your favorite city to go to football
wise is one football wise well I mean
it's easy to say green baby is that
special always love Kansas City that
specialist we said it's a college
atmosphere no you know what I miss I
miss Chicago because they have them very
good so we haven't had them on Sunday
night for for a while but that's Chicago
is a cool place to go to a football game
as well
Dallas is terrific too I just asked Rich
Eisen this last hour I said if you could
pick now for their futures you bought
stock and deshaun Watson or dak Prescott
oh man I hope I die both stocks I would
know you can't why not I'm calm I call
you know one broker and then you call
the other broker
I wouldn't shorty the guy I tell you
that because we've only seen Watson a
couple of times right but we saw him a
lot in college yes we saw Prescott a
little bit in college but I've seen him
a lot in the NFL right and I think you
might get a 50/50 on that now with what
we've seen with Watson it and how would
you like to be the Cleveland Browns well
you're looking at deshaun Watson and
going what were we thinking right
meanwhile Osweiler's there he goes from
the Browns he's gone Watson's in Houston
I mean he's off to a fantastic start you
know we've got him this week on yeah
Sunday Night Football you're aware of
that aren't you yeah I'm gonna get to
that the Texans and I thought maybe you
could bring that up on the air to
Collinsworth and say would you take to
Shaun Watson or dak Prescott why don't
you bring it up on the preview I would I
could throw it to you guys and say hey I
want to ask Chris the best quarterback
in the state of Texas is but the thing
is it's like saying to somebody hey
would you like to have a New York steak
or a rib eye I mean they're both good if
you're a steak lover as am i I don't
know where I'm going
I don't know where I'm going with this
but it came back to me right came back
the food what it did yeah but at the
start of the season when he was drafted
you would have you would have taken dak
Prescott from what he did his rookie
season oh sure and now were two games in
with deshaun Watson right and all of a
sudden people have seen enough we saw
him against the Patriots we saw him
against the Titans defense where they
put up fifty seven yeah he's more than a
shooting star I mean we know that yeah
but I mean he's not gonna go out and
throw for four touchdowns and run for
one every week know so I'm curious to
see him this week look the more the
other teams get to know about him
everybody is just in this league they
will but it's exciting to have a guy
like that in the league it's exciting to
have both of those guys in the NFL
Texans Chiefs coming up on Sunday Night
Football is Paulding at the door there
yeah oh well so we got ahold of Gerry's
cakes and torrents and they brought us a
cake Eric can you bring it in it's a
nice cake I love the big German kids
yeah okay you got this cake that oh nice
and the owner wanted to come in to to
say hello look at that cake feels like
it's great thank you for coming in and
Jerry and Jerry made this that's the
amazing part of this I meant on the left
over there there wow you know I gotta
give this crew credit they normally
don't do much work but man did you guys
outdo yourself with all the surprises so
I got Al Mike I got two of the greatest
ever
I got Jerry and El Michaels old looking
both looking for a golf course right
I don't know I don't understand how you
do here this early you'd normally be
tramping around bel-air Country Club
today I'm just getting in oh okay come
on the other side of the clock right now
have you have you guys played golf
before we have yeah because Jerry's
really good I think yeah I saw him
playing cards one day and at bel-air I
liked I just love when Jerry's on the
range he takes an 8-iron and there's a
flag out there and like 115 balls are
within three feet of the flag well well
when the finest golfers I've ever played
about you know basketball was your life
but or did you take the same kind of
competitiveness to golf Jerry could you
turn it on and off like that well you
know I think you know when you first
started anything Dan it's it's such a
shock to pick up something that all of a
sudden you can see yourself getting
better at and I've always felt that golf
might be the most addictive game there
is and particularly for young kids once
you start learning how to hit the ball
correctly it seems like you're in the
slit your every day goes by you're
trying to do something different and
once you get to a certain point in in
your in time when your game gets pretty
good then you get really confident about
but it's the most frustrating game and I
like to be frustrated okay I really do
usually you do well that's a good game
then because you never master it no no
one mastered that game Wow I believe
Jerry shot 29 on the back nine one time
correct 28 but there was a penalty
stroke in there somewhere
no I didn't think so that day I Paulie
are you shocked me here so you got a
cake
dan Patrick show cake you you got Jerry
West to come in Fritzi got Jerry West to
come in yeah we called mr. West who's
been nothing but nice to us and he said
get up in this early in the morning and
bring a cake in no problem yeah 14 let
me just tell you one short notice he's
getting ready to get on a plane to San
Francisco his wife Karen was kind enough
to help us track him down he couldn't
have been nice as we all knew he would
be and I'm very short notice he changed
his plans and made arrangements to be
here for you on the 10th anniversary one
of your idols Jerry West oh and I said
this to these guys that every time I see
I see my dad
we thank you my dad you know he loved
the way you played so the last time
you're here I was pretty emotional well
thank you you know it's one of the thing
I think strange things about sports is
that it's just amazing to me how people
become so attracted with all sports
today this country has changed greatly
because the sports
I watched today and I watch the all the
talk that goes on in this country and
other derogatory things that men said
and I always have felt that particularly
in basketball it's probably the greatest
leveling of society coming together my
teammates I was a lot of times in my
life I was predominately you know just a
couple of white players in team but I
walked away from this game having
greater respect for my black teammates
and maybe anyone and to this day every
time I see some of these incredible
players play it thrills me to see where
this game has come and our greatest
stars are revered today by everyone in
this country throughout the world and in
basketball they're almost always always
black and it thrills me to see that
happen I want to thank both you guys for
coming in do you mean the world to me
you really do and I if you want to have
some cake Jerry you look like you're
still in playing shape there my thanks
too to Jerry West and Al Michaels thank
you again for stopping by to celebrate
our 10 year anniversary the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience